action you are listening to the dollop
on the all things comedy network
my name
is dave anthony good better each week i
read a story from american history
to get there
can we get a prompter in here my friend
an idiot gareth reynolds who has no idea
what the topic is going to be about hey
everybody
that's how you do it jack
let's do this episode like we're a
morning radio show yeah you know which
one i am oh
we've been on the amphitheater this
friday night friday night two for what
hot dogs it's amazing that after all
these years morning radio has not
changed
yeah it's still moon cow yeah and moon
cow man yeah
he's the night guy man cow's the am guys
yeah he's a morning ship but moon cow's
the late night shift yeah he gets the uh
you know
late commute all the way through
midnight yeah he gets the it's mainly
for truckers
moon cow uh
and then decal they can handle the
daytime shift uh-huh yeah yeah it's a
good it's a good dust with a cow radio
the only radio full of cows everybody
here works here has technically a cow
we got night cow midnight cow
midnight cow drive time cow lunch cow
we got dinner cow tonight hope
everyone's ready to throw some cow chow
where's draft time dinner time couch
have traffic
i'm just gonna have to keep going until
i put in the music
that's right sundays
early before lunch after breakfast we
have brunch cow crunch cow holy [ __ ]
how's it going yeah we got cap calf man
cat 5 comes in from four to six
give me that baby talk
keep going not a fully formed cow but
account nonetheless it is kathmandu
i'm the [ __ ] hippo guy dave okay my
name is gary my name is it for fun and
this is not gonna become the tickling
podcast okay this is like adam and a
five-part confession
now hit him with a puppy
you both present sick arguments no sleep
don't hippo that's like hip-hop action
party
all right all right david we're out of
cow stuff um uh we have a few things to
announce um one of the things that we
have uh announced is that we will be
doing a uh one night only live show that
is timed perfectly for people in
australia and new zealand the show is
november 18th at 6 p.m melbourne time uh
and the show will be available for 48
hours after and if you're like hey i
want to watch a show well then you know
it's not just for people in australia
and new zealand anybody can watch the
show we're doing it with moment house so
you can go to momenthouse.com
the dollop uh and get tickets for that
show that's november 18th 6 p.m and it's
6 p.m melbourne time so what time is it
for people who would want to watch it
live dave it's like 11 for us or is it
even later
it might be later yeah so it's like if
you want to watch it live it's gonna be
like midnight definitely around there
one something like that so
you know there's people who like doing
that uh i will be doing a lot of cocaine
that's usual that's before every show we
also have other shows we're doing uh in
person shows we will be uh november 5th
we'll be at the palace of fine arts in
san francisco saturday november 6 we
will be at the crest theater in
sacramento that's this weekend people so
let's dance and then friday december
10th we will be at uh north park
observatory in san diego friday december
10th uh so go to dolloppodcast.com
for any information on that and then i
had my dates brought up and it was ready
to go and it was right there ready to go
and there they are awesome okay we're
back five four we still recording aaron
awesome okay so i will be in bozeman
montana friday november 12th saturday
november 13th uh and then i will be and
that's uh last best comedy in bozeman
montana seattle washington friday
november 19th uh saturday november 20th
i'll be at laughs comedy club and then i
will be friday november 26th through the
27th i will be at the denver improv
that's in denver appleton wisconsin
december 2nd through december 4th uh
that's at the skyline comedy club
chicago illinois i'll be at the den
theater sunday december 5th from 7 to 9
den theater and then indianapolis friday
december 17th 7-9 p.m and then i'll be
in fort wayne december 18th at the tiger
room somerville massachusetts december
19th
the crystal ballroom go to
garethreynolds.com for all ticket
information for that and we should
mention we have uh one of my best
friends luke simmons sitting in for this
episode wait what uh oh sorry you should
have known that you were i didn't give a
[ __ ] you actually suggested it i did not
listen
he can come as long as he's not on that
luke a very talented writer comedian
this is luke yeah you've met him a bunch
yeah he actually sat on stage once for a
show
dressed like conor mcgregor and he
didn't even have a microphone we just
had him sit in a chair oh that was the
mighty body boss tones guy i thought
that was just my seat
yeah no he had a nice seat that's all
yeah
he had the probably the best seat that
would be we should do that for one show
and just put a chair on stage and have
like the uh sure be like right here what
is this right here right here so just
about 10 feet away from where there is a
great view it's kind of stressful
because they notice you fidgety don't go
to the bathroom it's weird for everyone
don't pull an apple out of your
uh-oh pocket we do it yeah let's do it
okay yeah you ready are you scared yes
long time first time happy to be here
yeah
on cal radio
always with cow paws
august 1
1886 year of our lord
jesus christ okay
evelyn walsh maclean was born in
leadville colorado great that's where
the lead is great gosh you guys know
that yeah now we've just moved it to
flint
so
her parent that's not
you're right it's cleaned up it's right
well that's not true but it's wrong to
talk it's cleaned up we're trying to
ignore it if we don't talk about it it's
fine there's a guy outside flint with a
megaphone who's like we're trying to
ignore it let it be
her parents were thomas walsh and kerry
bell reed
his mom was a schoolteacher dad was a
carpenter
uh she had one younger brother vincent
v-i-n-s-o-n
we can't afford the tea
we tooled our money together we're a
t-shirt of vincent well what are we
gonna do he's vincent
it would still be an e
it's vincent it was isn't there a c in
vincent yeah sometimes when they're
making the baby crib they just pick
based on what numbers or letters are
available sure then it's like scrabble
yep his son's named barry
oh god with uh one r and uh
a j that we cut off the bottom of so it
looks like an eye
i mean his real name's barge
it's dutch spelling it's b-a-r-j but we
tried to make the j look like an eye for
barry
what was your what is the boy's name i'd
prefer barge i gotta be honest ah too
late we already i mean you just tell
people it's barge
that's fine so we're done here that'll
be a thousand dollars what that's a
thousand dollars why am i paying for
that because we got you your goddamn
crib here in within the month
what within the month that you wanted it
for we got it here i think i live in the
worst country where's little barge
a little scamp well his name's barry
because you guys
um
split the baby call it bearjie bearjie
looking for that money still uh so the
family moved around
they're going from mining town to mining
town because thomas is trying to strike
a rich prospecting gold right in
leadsville
and he's a carpenter
he should have gone to goldsville
he's a carpenter who wants to start
mining uh well he is mining but he does
he does carpentry but then he mines it's
his uh hustle his side hustle yeah
uh there's a place called goldville over
that mountain we'll stay in ledville and
look for goldberg that was it
leadville's where it's gonna be oh look
how rusty this is look there's money
town keep your eyes focused on
leadsville
when evelyn was 10 thomas came into her
room and said quote daughter i've struck
it rich
he had oh uh he had found a mine in
colorado that became one of the richest
minds ever discovered wow okay
so now they're loaded
and they move towards barry your new
crib's here can i get it buy a new name
uh well listen marge also i'm 14. yeah i
know it's been a while but dad struck it
rich we can afford whatever name you
want now marge
and we're leaving leadsville for
lodesville
right
so uh
washington for some reason is where all
the rich people are moving at this point
let's all move to washington
columnist sarah booth conor i quote it
was a big thing
then to come to washington and become
part of the national scene and that's
when all these big houses were built it
was considered the thing to do to come
here to go to parties maybe three
parties in one night okay
so he plucks out a million dollars for a
60-bedroom house jesus on massachusetts
avenue back then that's just [ __ ] that's
like one of those 70 million houses now
or whatever well 60 bedrooms oh you
gotta have a bedroom for every what shoe
what's the i mean really at what point
are you like i don't know like i don't
have 60 friends but you know what's
great about uh having 60 rooms is
you can go to a different room and be
like god this is cool i've been here
a year and a half i've never been in
this room now do you live here yeah i do
yes oh i'm rumpelstiltskin hello hello
did you come with the house no i just
have been living here for a few years i
had a horrible situation with an evil
woman who took a baby from me okay well
there's a door uh lock on the outside so
i'm gonna lock you in okay let's just
let you die and then i'll come back here
it'll be a new surprise in like six
months no well be good to feed me but
all right take care i don't think that's
gonna happen okay we don't have a
kitchen we only have 60 rooms no kitchen
that's bad moves yeah it was not smart
all right
no bathroom either
like i have some bottoms nope all right
so uh
so yeah a million dollars so they they
ate off gold plates
because they're cheap
we've got so much who wants gold gravy
uh let's be a crazy stereotype eat your
plates everybody
uh so evelyn grows up just accustomed to
being rich and one day she told her dad
that walking to school was quote trying
for my dignity
so hard yeah so hard so he bought her a
blue carriage and two matching horses
with a coachman in silk uh a hat hat and
gloves good good so and how old is she
uh she's like 10 around okay so she
already felt that walking was
undignified for her at 10. or 12. she
might be on 12. okay yeah no she's not
wrong no she's not it's terrible she's
right yeah
uh he encouraged her to just spend like
crazy on clothes so she's wearing the
latest stuff from paris sure she changed
your wardrobe and hairdo is it like a
brewster's millions situation does he
have like a certain amount of time to
spend this money he's the richest guy in
washington dc so he's just like [ __ ] it
i mean whatever the mind the gold mine
he found was like [ __ ] crazy okay
so um and how often did that that was
rare yeah that didn't happen okay mostly
it was you getting killed by another guy
over a hole in the ground better
um
so my dick goes in that ted
what that's my [ __ ] that's my mind
uh i've been [ __ ] it well i've been
looking for gold oh well i'm probably
gonna be hard to find i've been really
banging that hole it's really big yeah
yep a man can walk in there well
as a as a prospector who's been watching
can i suggest a my niger trois where he
[ __ ] it you work it and i watch
because i like what i see i mean i'm i'm
the creep here and i'm creeped out by
this guy that guy's [ __ ] up really
weird
not a bad idea i don't have a problem
with it it grows on you i don't hate the
pitch all right well i'm i do i do this
with my clothes on them um a dealer's
choice but not okay i'm taking off the
clothes and i'll get a mind this mind
all right now chain him up let's take
his money oh no
god i wouldn't been wanting to be
chained up for years
so okay so
she would change her watermelon hairdo
for each day of the week oh my god
she drank cream to mint out of her dad's
liquor cabinets she blew her allowance
allowance on herman tales which are like
mink tails okay and drove her
governesses to quit oh my lord in her
carriage in her carriage
out
her parents sent her to europe to study
french and art but she spent her time
buying clothes and escaping chaperones
to travel around she's just 12 13. yeah
she's she's like 14 probably this okay
maybe 15. okay she's right
um
she once bribed her parents into buying
her mercedes by telling them she was in
love with a very unpleasant italian
prince
who hasn't done that yeah that's just
the teen year that's how i got my vw
jetta
i told my mother hey well i don't have
to tell you i'm in love with the prince
in italy so i think probably gonna go
pretty good for us unless of course i
have something to get me around brown
deer cheddar
would you trade giuseppe for a jedi i
mean he's everything mother i don't know
he's a spicy meatball
[Laughter]
uh so
when she came back from europe she had a
crazy new hairdo
uh conrad quote it was so complicated
she couldn't wash her hair because
nobody could put it back together
and her father hated it and all the
girls at school made fun of her and the
headmistress said you just can't do that
her father asked well what would it take
you
what would it take for you to make sure
you're taking a hairstyle what would it
take to make you put your hair back like
everybody else and evelyn said jewelry
wow so she's learning the game of
leverage very early and well just [ __ ]
up your hair how does a hairstyle get so
complicated that you can't wash it i'm
picturing flock of seagulls uh-huh i'm
picturing like multiple like braids
going into a beehive yeah yeah well it
is around that time so she could have
had birds in there or whatever
on top the windmill yeah yeah it's just
the first
home farm really just a fully
functioning farm on her head
oh the goats are fighting so he bought a
very expensive necklace to get rid of
the hair dude now she loved jewelry if
she didn't have jewelry on she sent that
she said that meant she wasn't feeling
well and the family should call a doctor
god damn what's wrong you don't have any
rings on
oh my god how long she been like this
god damn it a day i guess
she needs mouth to mouth
what a terrible terrible just talk about
raising that kid wrong well that's what
i'm thinking like i i would imagine that
even if you
yeah like you want to spoil i mean i
understand being like i'm going to spoil
my child but it's like i mean you're
making a real dick but he it's not but
like the people who just go out to
strike it rich and do yeah like they
don't it's not like they built up
something and slowly they literally just
walked and found a hole i know but i
have money i still would be like you can
have some of it but i want to just be
like you need a carriage
i'm going to say somebody who's watched
a lot of my super sweet 16 episodes it
usually turns out pretty well that's
true
they are around it eventually they do
ground themselves eventually
you need to find the limits yeah sure
you can know sure
uh so uh evelyn quote it's only when the
thing i buy creates a show for those
around me that i get all my money's
worth i cannot remember when i did not
hunger for thrills that is key to all my
recklessness i hate boredom most
that's amazing too like that's not that
that is one of the things that happens
when you're rich is that you talk about
regular person problems and pretend that
solving them in your life is unique to
you
you know where you're just like
personally i just don't like to get
depressed so i have all this like yeah
no we all don't like to get depressed we
all just don't afford helicopters like i
think the helicopter just kind of feels
like i i personally hate it when i'm
down like i cannot handle sadness you
know i'm like yep we all we all feel
that way
yeah and they also they can't
they they get no feeling from normal
things right right so they have to do i
mean that's why the ebsting thing
happened because they just they can't
like after all normal sex well i bought
it sorry allegedly allegedly
we don't want to besmirch the good name
of jeffrey epstein on our show
so
uh authors dan and leslie landrigan said
evelyn was quote feisty reckless
kind-hearted impetuous a gambler and a
show-off
did like kind-hearted accidentally get
put in there
she was like she did have a side of her
that was nice right when they hunted the
poor from helicopters it was
tranquilizers
she'd pet them tag them and release them
thank you he's one of mine
get in my hairdo
so her brother vincent was the same in
1905 he crashed his mercedes with evelyn
in the car and he died
and she was seriously injured
the doctors ended up giving her morphine
get jewelry get jewelry in an iv bag now
hurry move move
they ended up giving her morphine during
her recovery and she became addicted oh
dear but they did wean her off okay um
they took it away she got clean
now as far as men evelyn had a guy
that
had been pursuing her for years
ned mclean
they met in a dance class when she was
11 and he was eight okay sure and he was
instantly in love interesting so he's
one of those kids
creepy yeah yeah a little too much yeah
wears a suit yeah
when he became a young man he started
proposing
at least a dozen times they were engaged
at least six times wow
on and off you know she would break it
off because he's a huge drunk okay and
i'm still picturing like eight and nine
year olds so they're everybody's getting
older okay well and you're 14 i'm 11.
it's time we settle down i want to quit
drinking baby i'm almost 10. it doesn't
even suit me anymore
uh ned would drink so much as sometimes
he made a sling out of a handkerchief to
keep his hand steady for his glass oh my
god at 21. what your tables invented he
said
it feels like table does the
job of this there's no way to put this
thing cause you're surrounded by tables
ned just look left or right there's a
bar you're at a bar
[Music]
uh get me my coaster sling
ned i'll need another sling for my
cocktail peanuts
[Laughter]
he's just got eight slings
ned was um
and that was good looking he was shy
uh his grandfather became rich as a
boilermaker and steamboat builder okay
and then
ned's father
uh with another rich guy kind of sucked
cincinnati drive through kickbacks and
shakes down and corruptions like that he
just they just took over the town and
then okay great they like what happened
like what's happening with america right
right
yeah i like that we've built it to a
bigger version yes
and then when the city was in such bad
shape that riots broke out he left for
dc i don't like this town these people
are real jerk-offs about money to be
honest
uh there he amassed a larger fortune
going into utilities and banking he
founded dc's trolley system he owned the
cincinnati choir in the washington post
part of the cincinnati red stocking so
he's everything [ __ ] this is ned's
father so these two the two richest
people exactly they are just rich as
[ __ ] and they have a connection which is
that we don't like to be touched by
poor's that's right
uh ned's mother was the daughter of
edward f uh beal a very famous guy a
military hero explorer diplomat friend
of ulysses grant so they're it's just
all right there right
and that pedigree was something evelyn
liked right military heroes sure yeah
so ned also obviously raised a spoiled
rich kid
which is probably why he and evelyn got
along so well right
um they were children of dc's two
richest families high society kids and
inseparables it's funny if like if
you're his dad to like find out that
your son is double slinging it at bars
he's getting so hammered
i really tried to raise him properly
what is he doing he has things for his
drunk hands
he's an inventor yeah
we call him puppet man
uh ned's uh
netapp he apprenticed as a cub reporter
at the post as a cover
like a brand new reporter okay sure
obviously when they're hustling you know
they're like hustling right stories okay
he would drive two assignments in his
huge expensive packard roadster
which like the weekly salary uh the
weekly upkeep was like more than a
reporter's i've seen this i've seen this
on set before a little bit where it'll
be like someone has like a you know
father or something in the so this yeah
a very successful person's child is like
a pa you know like this i mean this
person they came in there it's just
nicer to everything than me you know
what i mean like i got most of your
coffees but i spilled yours in my lambo
so
uh he uh he was big in the dc nightlife
obviously he's a boozer
he's a dashing bachelor at the time okay
he's a dashler
evelyn finally agreed to marry ned when
he promised he would quit drinking
uh-huh that's fine this always works it
does it's never enough what is the way
to do it that's the number one way to
get sober absolutely it's like a crash
diet but for love we haven't discussed
any timeline so that's a good move yeah
right that's right okay yes i'll get
sober for a day
at a point in the future
uh she wants a big society wedding ned's
mom wants dad wants to wait a few months
and years
mountain his mom wants to have it in in
bar harbor up in maine but ned talks
evelyn into eloping okay wow and they
they go to colorado and they get married
on july 22nd 1908. she's 22 he's 19.
okay
society pages gushed over the new couple
and they're
i just i i it's amazing to me how it
how we still do this how we still like
elevate never changed you know and and
celebrate the level of affluence that
these people have yeah
imagine ah they're getting together
just like what the [ __ ] we should be
like
like we should have pitchforks most of
our days yes
to prob them closer to each other
get them in a pen so they mate they get
together and mate
yeah it's just like snow panthers
he's in here he's in her everybody these
are the only two surviving rich in
ledsville
it's our last two kardashians we're
trying to get them to mate
so
they get married and then their
dads give
give them each a hundred thousand
dollars okay so two hundred thousand
dollars to use on a three-month european
and middle eastern honeymoon oh my god
that's 6.5 million so they got they got
the equivalent of the 6.5 there's
millions to take a three-month vacation
six million dollar trip can you imagine
trying to spend million dollars in that
amount of time i'd be
very hard yes i guess can we just buy
the boat and then we'll give it back
later we really are we have too much
just crash the boat into the shore and
we'll just walk off yeah
all boats you crash and we step off
right right you buy a new boat yeah
every day like all right we'll take this
boat
so they went in in a packer can i shoot
you and kill you for this much money
okay oh great take it they had a
mercedes and they had a camel caravan
for part of it evelyn quote one day in
leapsig we lost patients with the fact
that we only had one mercedes and went
overnight to paris and bought an extra
one we just didn't have enough mercedes
you understand
how are you gonna get by with one
mercedes we looked ridiculous how can we
drive over all the poor people and we
damaged it very badly when we hit the
camel
but still they managed to blow through
all the money wow and when they
arrived in paris at the end of the trip
they didn't have enough money to pay the
hotel bill what
evelyn quote so i cabled my father and
he sent me fresh credit and his love
then i went to cartiers
uh that is the way i always get in
trouble when i have some money in my
hands they were lovely and of course
they knew me and dad and um
it's like an instagram story
she bought the star of east diamond
120 000
sure
and then dad were broke again and dad
will you cable more money i want to buy
the west store
bad news the credit is stale i'll need
some fresh please love you
she smuggled the diamond through customs
to avoid paying taxes wow i i love that
everyone hates taxes
and they just got
how are the rich allowed to hate dessert
they just start it's what i it's
hardcount you set up they don't have to
pay taxes that's the whole thing of it
it's amazing and then we pay taxes and
then they get taxes we're essentially
stealing our money yes yes it is it is
stealing yes
uh
the
diamond is so large that guests at her
house called it the craft stopper wow
i mean that all it just also shows you
how it's like
you'll stop using your carafe
it's not remarkable
i think it just fills up the top of the
neck of the bottle it's like i'm
imagining that baseball diamond from the
muppet movie yeah yeah sure i mean
that's i think that's what we're all
thinking about yeah we're all thinking
of the diamond from the muppet movie no
doubt
that one
now ned was made the washington post
business manager even though he's pretty
clueless right and who better to have
like tell you how to succeed in business
than a guy who's been given everything
yes yeah that's right here's what i did
i took a ton of my dad's money and just
played around with it
do that okay
look at it we're [ __ ] uh yeah that's
uh yeah yeah here's how to take a six
million dollar jaunt
the mistake a lot of people make is
paying taxes on the hundred and twenty
thousand dollar diamond you have when
you could just shove it inside the dead
camel you hit with the third mercedes
so
his father gave him a thousand dollars a
month allowance 30 000 a day right so
that's a lot of fun yes and also at some
point no more allowance i would say but
he always ran out daddy i need more
pocket money he always ran out so that
he would go to evelyn's dad and borrow
money can i have a pocket money from you
yes you get like seven 10k from here i
would hate to do stuff for it may i have
more to use for things i love
why don't more people do this i just
wrote a column about it in the paper and
everyone was very upset ask when you
need money ask papa
in december 1909 uh the mcleans had a
son and they named him vincent okay same
[ __ ] spelling which is not how you
spell they could afford the team it's
not even a name
no it's not he was dubbed by the press
and everybody else quote the 100 million
dollar baby due to his future financial
prospects
what a horrible life for a baby uh and
he had a reserved price that you could
purchase them for a hundred million
that's right yeah you could but yeah
yeah if you have it yeah yeah
so this freaked out the mcleans who were
worried about kidnapping right because
kidnapping was a thing at this time no i
mean that's what the papers are doing
they're like the most kidnappable baby
right here here's a picture of him and
this is his home address
boy anyone should take this thing
they'll make a killing
say he was pampered he was very guarded
he had
nurses he had servants he would get
tutors he had guards he slept in a
golden crib which was a gift from king
leopold of belgium who might be the
worst human being ever
yeah
i agree uh you can't uh
this child will be an [ __ ] i mean you
are you are without a doubt
yeah he has no chance that's what rich
people should do is they should have a
poor part of the house where you feel
poor and that's why you should raise
your children and at like 17 be like hey
it's not bad see oh it was so hard it's
like now you have character
now you can have some money or
counterpoint put them in a gold crib
from leopold and hang a mobile that's
all severed hands and feet from that's
good too the diamond mines that he ran
to pay for the gold oh that's wow too
yeah he's [ __ ] up
don't blame me i was raised in the rich
part of the house oh that's problematic
that's
all right that makes sense
so they moved into friendship which is
an enormous mansion
uh built built fortinet's father and
became known for constantly throwing
lavish parties okay so french they had
come to
friendship the boston globe quote
they're
oh they're one saw senators judges
diplomats cabinet members generals and
admirals famous personalities of every
kind so they're the [ __ ] place it's
the party they're always throwing
parties because
what else are they gonna do right now
that's true that's true when i've
watched the real housewives show before
you know been in relationships watching
the show i'm sure maybe a little bit
yeah not you on but never on my own but
maybe a little bit on my own and maybe
it's maybe
maybe i'm the one pushing to watch it
when i'm in the relationship all the
spin-offs maybe the whole yeah the
problem what i'm trying to
try to make is a new year i'm trying to
make it orange county the point i'm
trying to make is is that if you watch
any of these and i don't really know
what they are but let's say you're
watching salt lake city or you're
watching the real housewives of miami or
even the classic beverly hills or even
orange county i mean there's a lot to
choose from not new york okay honestly
bethany enough
but when you're watching these shows
which again i uh uh test yeah um it's
just the worst of every shirt all they
do is have parties every episode is
about someone throwing a party and the
drum and they feel real world stress
over the party they just
have real problems what's going on with
the ice sculpture well yeah it's that
sort of [ __ ] where they're just like i
can't believe she wore clogs
like they treat the littlest thing at a
party like a dire thing but it's all
they can do is just take really
extravagant expensive trips and just
have these [ __ ] parties and stuff
like that and that is basically all you
do yeah
again allegedly i've not
seen these
programs but um
the
google search tells you that
sure
and now i see you're wearing clogs was
this how you fell out i just hate lisa
i think she's so
at one year's eve party
40 cases of champagne were drunk before
dinner
they had 2 000 socialites at another
party
after seeing their ballroom because they
had a ballroom in the mansion
idaho senator william barra said quote
this is what brings on revolutions yeah
oh thank you
this is what they guillotine folks for
oh stop no really your head should be on
a pike oh that's so
you are
charming
evelyn's father also bought them
a big single style house named
briarcliff
it originally been built for montgomery
sears
now they considered tearing it down and
building something new but instead uh
decided to put in a bowling alley a
ballroom a nursery suite and a wing for
evelyn's mother
a wing
well it's hard to know if you should
tear it down or put in a bowling alley
yeah no i know we've all faced that
quandary yeah i only recently realized
that everyone has to name boats and now
i'm getting that there's a level of
house which also gets a good friendship
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
my house is named the [ __ ] the dirty
[ __ ] thomas thomas
welcome to my home the revolutionary
balls
wait either naming welcome to castle to
anus
i don't want i'm not coming to your
party well let me show you the back door
that's what i want you to walk through i
don't like this
no come
on so briar cliff was burgled at one
point and the cops thought it might have
been a plot to kidnap baby vincent okay
obviously this is their greatest fear
for sure yeah maybe live in a smaller
place
and he's already constantly being
watched by armed guards what a nice life
what a nice life to be in your gold crib
surrounded by gunned men that's right
when evelyn and ned
thought vincent was lonely
they rented a child from some parents to
be his friend you there you
stupid people i'm sorry poor babe face
uh you there fine you give us your child
we'd like to rent it to play with
no our son
child go please he's our boy we can't he
will be best friends with the best child
on earth he'll be fine we'll give you a
safety deposit in case we don't bring
him back yes there's a chance we keep
him how much would that cost the income
how much would it cost for you to be
done with him forever i can't put it our
intentions are to bring him back we're
just asking if we forget or think he's
firewood or something what's the price
what is uh do you even speak english no
uh i don't yes
five million yes great no problem there
you are people are [ __ ] what's this
child's name i don't know he's not mine
we're gonna call him ace and we don't
even care who you are come on ace
okay so
god rich people are out of their [ __ ]
minds i mean i'm also trying to picture
like how do you
like
you know you take like a regular kid to
like a gold crimped house it's not like
a regular kid's gonna be like cool or
just whichever parent gets the offer
first breaking it together honey okay
i'm gonna it's gonna sound crazy at
first what but where's the child well
that's the thing
what would you say our child is worth if
you had the ball parking absolutely
everything i've got me everything i've
got most of that
i don't know what's happening
i got almost everything for it you know
what i mean it's a good deal the longer
you say well unless we get his clothes
still they weren't dicks about no yeah
they didn't like them
so
in 1910 they're in paris sure obviously
and jeweler pierre cartier cartier
cartier
came to their hotel room to show them
the hope diamond excuse me
i have something i think you might want
to see hi
hello hi how are you
okay
thank you
got good news for you too huh okay
look you didn't tell me you bought a
kitten
[Applause]
where's a cat penis i just want to touch
it quickly huh that's just a pillow oh
my god i'm sorry i don't really know
what uh cats are so
the diamond you want to see it
let me pull it out of this box
i love you so much i [ __ ] you in the car
right there right here
the french scare me it's a cartier oh no
i see yeah yeah nice uh some bloods on
that from my teeth but other than this
this diamond is ready to roll
so the hope diamond is the most
amazing gem in the world
it's 47 carats
it's blue
and it's cursed
this is the tails from the [ __ ] yeah so
it is the largest diamonds in the world
you can see it's blue it's one of a kind
and it comes as a curse
at no extra charge
so cartier explains
how the curse had affected previous
owners
the truth is a little
but this is what
this is what is believed a gem merchant
named uh tavernae stole it from the
statue of the hindu goddess sitta at 80
he was torn apart and eaten by wild dogs
wow how long did he have between
stealing and being i don't know i mean
it seems like a while i don't think an
80 year old man steals it but yeah yeah
um
waited a long time he was like i'll tell
you what i don't think that there is
such thing as a curse after all oh no
seven dogs
hey they they are how they eat me
when princess de lembao had it she was
beaten to death by a french mop
marie antoinette owned it and we know
what happened there yeah everything's
fine
sultan abdul hamid bought it and then
lost his throne and his concubine who
wore it died young so
everybody who has it dying and if
someone came to my room and told me all
this would be like i don't want this
here oh i wouldn't be look how pretty it
is i would be like sorry worth it
if i had it every time i saw dogs i'd be
like run run
evelyn wasn't into it but not because of
the curse or the insane praise she
didn't like the setting right sure
interesting
let's let the rental child hold it yeah
okay where are my mom and dad
don't worry about it hey you're to hold
this pretty blue thing
can we have it set in his skull like
right at the top of his forehead oh like
a third eye it'll be lovely who are we
talking about you oh
yeah we're going to put a diamond in
your head and it'll be there forever i
don't and you'll follow me around oh
yeah
i own you yeah no i remember you told me
all right
sir
not much of a lie for all right that's
good one sorry vincent your friend is
getting reused as a diamond setting kill
him
kill him in front of me i want a new boy
so a few months later cartier came to dc
and he reset the diamond
it's still cursed and he let evelyn keep
it for a weekend okay wow
you know yeah sure
she put it on her dresser quote for
hours that that was a guy who worked for
right yes i would love to put uh some
clothes on you but uh all right just put
it down
thank you
it might roll off if i move yeah it's
okay okay just stay right there if it
rolls off you die oh interesting yes
great work uh quote for hours that jewel
stared at me at some point during the
night i began to want the thing
so ned agrees to buy the hope they have
problems yes
he agrees to buy the hope diamond for a
hundred fifty four thousand wow
evelyn didn't think the hope diamond
would bring her bad luck although she
was a little bit concerned but she
didn't believe in it okay but she's like
right so they included a buyback option
if they thought the diamond was bringing
the misery then they could return it
works like we're done
can i get like a a curse a curse
how much to recur reverse curse
what's that fee uh so there's just a
small restocking fee of 10 000 right get
all your money back trade i just want to
get rid of the curse yeah it might not
be gone right we don't know if you maybe
give it up
if uh if you give it up the curse might
still be there
um i don't do you have dogs i know by
design that a lot of them follow me
though
and there's mobs walking around from
time to time yeah yeah so you're
probably going to die
but let's do this great i'm not even
sure we landed on it i don't either
doing it so yeah
you're probably dead okay yeah hmm
good talk yeah good i guess on your end
i'm still a little like closure's not
there for you yeah
i'm uh looking for
but um how about this can i can i broke
or something here yeah we'll throw in a
pack of dogs there's a bunch of dogs oh
my god we have a we have a whole pack of
dogs rottweilers oh god haven't eaten in
a week oh no yeah it's gonna be fine
feels more by design than curse i'm
gonna paint you to look like a ham i
don't think that's fair it's what it is
get the hand paint
[Music]
so uh
right so they can return whatever they
want evelyn didn't believe in the curse
but she's cautious like i said quote i
must confess i know better and yet
knowing better i believe
by that i mean i never let my friends or
child touch it
that feels like what a rich person would
do anyway that feels like a good
scapegoat to get people to not get their
fingerprints all over us right yeah it's
such a weird
yeah because it's not the rich person
move to be like if anyone's cursed it's
me like that's just like with a selfish
person i think there's no curse she made
this all up just so people wouldn't get
their fingerprints no no julie don't
touch it
it's cursed
oh
it's [ __ ]
and the curse is already making you look
very bloated when you tried to put it on
so it's just oh you're not you're
wearing it yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's like i should run you should
uh so
her mother so she calls her
mother-in-law to tell her she bought it
and when evelyn tells her she's
purchased the hope diamond there's a
friend there also who's listening and
she almost faints and yells out it is a
cursed stone i don't believe in that and
i'm not gonna let my friends touch it so
shut up
they try to talk evelyn out of it
doesn't work she's bought it she's in
yeah soon after ned's mother came down
with a terrible cold ned flies her
doctor back from north carolina who's on
vacation doesn't she dies wow and then
the friend dies right after her oh dear
yeah
okay were they sneaking little they got
a little yappy like don't buy the
diamond and the diamond's like [ __ ] you
shut your goddamn mouse
i like that the diamond like corners
people but she's not around i understand
you've been talking a lot of [ __ ]
yeah i'm the hope diamond say to my
goddamn shiny face i just said you were
a little cursed oh really yes
because now you're about to die call it
the dogs oh we only got camels
bringing the camels eat this lady alive
your aunt beth was curbed and eaten by
camels
jesus christ yeah what a terrible curb
yeah curbside and then the camels came
over and ate yeah once she was put out
yeah i tell you i really thought they
were vegetarians camels yeah oh no they
store a lot of meat in those humps okay
yeah those humps are mainly bacon and
they eat people they love people that's
the thing people
think you gotta know about camels
they're very good in deserts they
hydrate a lot before any journey they
love to spit and they will eat a human
like it's a lasagna
jesus yeah i guess i just never i never
seen that the humps are basic they are
basically i saw a whole attenborough
thing on camels and i never saw the
david attenborough is a camel in a man
suit
okay yeah okay i yeah yeah now that
makes sense you read breitbart i am
breitbart yeah
weird answer yeah
so um
so right she dies and her friend dies
and
the diamond is kept in the mansion
during the day and then taken to a safe
deposit box box at the company building
at night it just seems so dumb yeah
ned bought a special car just to drive
the diamond back and forth and it had
armed guards trouble relating to these
people what it's so [ __ ] crazy that
this is a thing you want you have a
diamond car yeah a car for a diamond
you shouldn't be here part of me feels
like maybe it's just the genius way to
distract from the 100 million dollar
baby yeah which one do you go for the
rich baby or the diamond car
or you can't go for both or the babies
in the diamond car
it's just diamond code name but yeah i i
mean it just at some point it's like i
don't
it's cursed it's extremely expensive and
it has to have its own car to go away
every night it's like you kind of own it
but it's also kind of like weird it's
really weird yeah
uh so after her mother-in-law's death
evelyn had the hope diamond blessed in a
church that'll do it i'll take care of
it yeah as the minister did it lightning
hit a tree across the street and the
tree fell down get the [ __ ] out actually
no i think about actually you guys get
the [ __ ] out right now do you understand
me leave the church now
if anyone should object to the blessing
of this diamond speak oh god okay that's
the big guy no that was actually christ
jesus walked off the crucifix
uh publicly the host the hope diamond
increases their fame
and in turn that increased their concern
someone would kidnap vincent what do
they do can you just go somewhere go
away you can afford to
guess what guys we put the cursed
diamond on our 100 million dollar baby
so you don't want to take him you'd get
a curse yeah
he's got the world's most expensive
jammer goodness
he watched uh he he vincent's watched 24
7 by nurses and bodyguards there's just
always people around evelyn's father
died and she's grief-stricken and she
turned her old friend morphine
wow okay
and once again she's addicted and she's
also drinking a lot okay and ned's like
ned's also always plowed oh he is i
wasn't he's never stopped i'm still i
still plan to eventually get sober as
promised what's with marriage
once we get married we are married and
someday we will also be married and
sober yes
yeah
as i said we've been married for a
decade yeah but it's coming the whole
sober thing you but we were you're
supposed to be sober i am going to be
that's the cool thing like something we
can look forward to on our older age yes
well we'll be dead because of the hope
dive that might be when i sober up when
i die i didn't we don't know i like i
said i'll just stop drinking when i die
baby
it's not the best time to quit when your
dad has just been torn apart by dogs
which again i'm sorry about
so uh
yeah so she's drinking he's drinking
she is so [ __ ] up that
she's
she's not recognizing her own guests at
party parties wow and so to deal with
this ned has a sanitarium built on the
top floor of friendship where she could
recover how about name tags no just
build some names just build a sanitarium
on top of the house i mean what else
would you do you know what my wife is
sick why don't i build a hospital in the
house i mean you have too much money oh
wait she's not sick she's drunk we'll
just build a sanitarium doctor how bad
is it she didn't recognize almost half
of the two thousand guests
well we're just gonna lock the door and
keep you up here at night
she
so she's in the house so she ends up
just meandering around the mansion and
she thinks that lizard monsters are
crawling all over
so she's just junked up drunked up
junked and drunk she's thinking lizards
are gonna kill her
so but eventually they think they got
this diamond yes eventually they
she gets better it was served in a
monkey park
[Applause]
i don't know how much better she gets
like no one really i could find no one
went into it but it's a pretty slow
functional again i think she's still
drinking drinking i don't know if she's
doing morphine but she could have been
like uh she's doing less food but she's
just not seeing lizard mommy yeah
right
yeah look we just want to get you a
place where you're not seeing lizards
i'm trying the only thing i'm trying to
quit is seeing lizards
oh we can just move those out those were
there to guard the baby and the jewels
oh yes listen's out hello it's been a
pleasure to work with you oh i'm sorry
the lizard monsters were real yes i
hired them so great
thank you for coming thank you for
coming
i'm sad that it has to end this way but
um if you ever have any sure
other needs yes we'd love to be a part
all of us were just really informed a
bit of our own family here and i'd like
to personally apologize for eating your
dad that's fine that's fine
there were a couple of missteps i mean
we knew going we messed up a couple of
years yeah i mean your visit monsters we
were going in can we just eat you before
we go then
all right all right what do you have
anything lined up what's your next uh
next thing well we're not sure exactly
but we're i mean we're gonna go try to
live with some families in dubuque okay
yeah they're trying to freak a daughter
out because she's probably engaged to an
italian man okay well that makes sense
well have fun with that yeah it's cute
but it's been a fun project yeah i mean
yeah good time really nice having you
around
anywho i'm sober so um
sex yeah well for you i mean
just has
such connections to this place we did
yeah we did
hello hug goodbye how about if you just
rub your belly
so uh ned's father john r came down with
jaundice and incurable hiccups jaundice
um okay and um sorry the last part again
incurable hiccups it's a nightmare
i'm sorry these are chronic hiccups i
would 100 believe it was diamond related
if someone i knew came down with it like
i would also the doctor i'd be like what
are you saying he has forever hiccups
medically speaking your father will
never stop hiccuping they're fatal
they are fatal
we think he has about 19 000 hiccups
left before he passes
oh my god
i just got
i can't word from the doctor
yeah
turns it boo
no sorry didn't it
have you tried holding your breath yeah
no that's literally if anyone says that
again i'm going to like lose my mind
i feel like i can have a regular
life but you can't i don't want you to
hear me love me jesus christ the curse
is real i love you
[ __ ] nightmare love your father come
here i love you son
there's something i have to tell you
when you were a little boy i hired an
actor to play because i was on the where
if you say the hook diamond too many
times oh my god dog shows perfect timing
buddy well done
oh that was great um
so
so yeah so he becomes paranoid the dad
the dad also becomes on top of hiccups
and uh jaundice so he's a yellow
hiccuping paranoid just a yellow hiccup
man and he barricades himself inside of
his mansion
because he thinks ned is trying to
poison him
and if ned goes over there he threatens
to shoot him okay
so ned hires the pinkertons oh my god to
help get him safely into the mansion
where he patches things up with his dad
wow so he has a pinkerton like
entourage who hasn't done that well
you're not getting along with him to go
see his hiccuping yellow dad that's
barricaded himself in a room that's
right
this time i mean the pinkerton's opened
that door they're like he was [ __ ]
serious
i thought he was being like hyper
[ __ ] crazy but this guy's actually
yellowing hello
i'm quiet yellow now
it's gotten worse
uh so he dies on june 9th 1916. he's
gonna hiccup for about another two years
post death
um the will
does not leave the post and the enquirer
to ned instead it's placed in a trust oh
interesting so he did not trust that
well his estate could not be split up
until 20 years after the death of his
grandchildren
wow okay he clearly thought ned was
unfit to run the businesses which is
news to ned because he had always told
ned for years he would say to ned i'm
holding the post just for you wow
like and then he the will comes he's
like ah i didn't [ __ ] you were [ __ ]
ned a lot of lies were told to you
so ned's very upset he's only going to
get an allowance so they sue just like
regular time yeah they sue and ned
become ends up becoming co-trustee of
the estate who is
the estate trust and and i assume the
whatever you sue the will whoever i'm
suing his grandchildren i'd like them
all dead yes they're babies i could just
kill the kids and then i get the [ __ ]
money and it's just waiting out that
20-year clock we're gonna let the kids
play with the hope diamond for the
afternoon
um so
he sues he gets
he becomes co-trustee of the estate and
also editor-in-chief of the two
newspapers okay so really the will meant
nothing yeah i mean basically he said my
dad was crazy and you can't really argue
with that because he's jaundice
hiccuping and
locked in his house you know i want to
make some chips
[Applause]
the pinkertons will back me up and when
have they ever not been trustworthy
so he actually steps in becomes a little
bit responsible at first he turned the
post into a from a very decent newspaper
into a reactionary sophomoric one
created by reporters right
ned doesn't care about politics at all
which it's a dc paper so that's not
great he loves ba he loves baseball
hunting and horse racing he owns so many
horse races that he bought land in
virginia and built a stable okay
training track
so and i there i hunt horses with babe
ruth
my perfect day
authors dan and leslie lanigan quote
mclean was a difficult man charming
suspicious changeable a falling down
drunk a plausible liar and a wanton
womanizer but really took takes a turn
for the last few yeah you're like it's
great yeah great hair great attitude
beats his friends takes money real jerk
off
i do love the potpourri descriptions
yeah yeah so he's seen in dc as like a
kind-hearted buffoon he's naive a little
bit of a playboy they love that there
how long until he has a show on cnn
sunday soon
so they have two more kids and a
daughter they have two more boys and a
daughter okay
ned and evelyn
start fighting a lot okay
uh at one point she charters a yacht in
a rage and he sends 60 telegrams until
she comes back
yacht chartering in a rage
just [ __ ] you shouldn't have access to
just i just hate rich people yeah it's
like you can't make a getaway in a yacht
like me for i need a yacht now hurry all
right all right
jesus christ
they're really [ __ ] terrible like
these this sounds a lot like two guys
who have never slammed the door on a
yacht behind them that's serious that's
true
uh so uh
uh they start hanging out with alice
roosevelt oh boy yeah episode
and her husband at their house
alice described it as a quote a general
atmosphere of waistcoats unbuttoned feet
on the desk and spittoons alongside
so it's just a lot of casual hanging out
drinking and partying and spitting and
spinning well spitting was a thing yeah
i know
forever yeah we've covered parties and
it's coming back it's coming back
finally
um this is where ned met senator warren
harding
warren was married to florence she
always badgered him
and she had an angry voice and she'd
poke until he exploded in rage and
yelled quote god damn it shut up and
then she'd shut up for a while
that was their relationship oh beautiful
yeah his glove is crazy uh warren kept
whiskey in his office desk drawer and he
and ned hit it off right yeah they've
whisked him
yeah drawer whiskey yes
in 1919 assuming it was in something it
wasn't just sloshing around there on its
own no no it was in a flashlight like a
punch ball you just dip a straw down
into that and let's put two cups in here
wipe the bottom
i love whiskey i love whiskey i hate my
wife i hate your wife
in 1919 despite people always watching
him vincent got away from his valet and
ran into the street was hit by a car and
killed wow what so he was just hammered
without his ballet no this is the boy oh
no vincent oh no i'm so sorry i hit your
child i got distracted by that diamond
he was wearing oh my god he's the most
guarded kid in the [ __ ] world someone
let it i mean a man oh my god yeah i
mean it's terrible that he died but i
also i do feel for the valet oh yeah it
was probably like you know i've told
this so am i gonna stay on here or you
need to run into the woods and dig a
hole and get in that hole and you'll
live there from now on go ahead and get
it before there will i get a weekly
check you will get nothing go live in a
hole now that'll be your life do you
understand can i no can i you should be
going a letter of recommendation for
your next what job yes you killed the
you i didn't kill him yes you did he was
a runner yeah he was just a child he's a
crazy you watch him he's a crazy idea as
the driver of the car maybe we swap
lives
that works
there's no parent trap there'll be more
there we can find another child you
bought one before replacing the child
what if we ran to look alike yes all
right now we're finally getting
somewhere god damn it for a while this
conversation was directionless now we're
talking about buying a child to make
that child the one that looks similar
very close and ann will answer to
vincent i mean basically i got you a new
child like a better one like an upgrade
where the hell are we gonna get a kid
we just buy one like we do we don't have
enough time one of us might have to
dress up like the kid and we might have
to spray paint his tail if it's a
different color great
well i think we're getting a good spot
uh that's what matters
so
so the claims that we're at the kentucky
derby when this happened
um
many now are like look the hope diamonds
are [ __ ] cursed yeah i mean what
hurts what do you give in
evelyn keeps it close by usually
under sofa cushions
what that's where you keep a diamond the
hope diamond treated like a quarter that
fell through your couch she wore there's
a few nickels some quarters the hope
diamond some gum tums
some grass oh there's the remote uh
there's the remote we found the apple
remote
she wore it at parties with the star of
east diamond and another diamond show
she had three diamonds
she likes looks like she's from another
planet yeah she looks crazy from krypton
two of the curses cancel each other out
but then the third is kind of a
free-floating curse and i just want
everyone to know i'm wearing a cursed
diamond so if you want to laugh leave a
circle around me
she wore to the races while swimming on
an arctic fishing trip she even wore it
during minor surgery once i'll just put
it here
the diamond on my appendix and then we
won't have to take it out
i mean
what in the [ __ ] it just is i mean it is
just it is obviously just affluence out
of control yes so it's someone who just
cannot recognize reality
and and has no i think i would say has
no idea of self like doesn't know what
she yeah i mean i look obviously like
eight you know i don't believe a thing
or an item can be cursed however if
someone told me it was cursed and then
everyone around me started dying i would
be like i think i'm done yeah it's not
great i'm not i'm not gonna wear it
anymore instead of being like oh but i
wanted for post-op
[Laughter]
or
potentially
the people who are rich enough to buy it
inevitably are at the top of the tower
and it's like where can i go but up
right down all the way down oh it must
be a curse yeah marie antonio my choices
i know if it weren't for that nasty
diamond
[Laughter]
um
she sometimes put it on her great dane
and he wore it around what the [ __ ] is
it sometimes i hang it over his tail to
cover his butthole when he gets a heart
on i put it on there
uh it was said i don't believe this but
it was some people said vincent had it
in his pocket when he was hit by the car
which he could have but
they were at the kentucky derby
yeah i bet it was in the safe but still
but if it wasn't i could see him pulling
it out from the silver coaster we
wouldn't know if the kid had the diamond
i think
yeah be like oh my god
no i put it on the horse that broke its
leg during the first round
at the derby
so i can prove it was elsewhere you can
prove it
horses love carrots
so after the death
and because he's friends with harding
ned throws himself into politics good
good
good he's got the perspective we need to
be engaged and understanding to the
comments that's right he helps harding
using his news i'm just like you when i
have someone who doesn't really feel
connected to the world i build a
sanitarium at the top of my castle
we're all suffering in the same way just
how you want some health care i know
what that's like i built a hospital at
my home
and we have to tackle the greatest
threat facing our nation diamond curses
we all agree how what will we do what
will we do to stop diamond curses and
why do people have to pay for their own
bowling alley maintenance thank you we
need a stimulus that says these lanes
will get greased on our behalf
what we came up with is that bowling
alleys will be tax free all right
whoo
hard again me hard to get come on
everyone
so
uh he helps him with his papers the
mcleans would were often by his side
during campaign stops and harding wins
okay
and ned is rewarded by being put in
charge of the inaugural uh festivities
sure
but his plans are [ __ ] crazy over the
top fancy huge yeah and that's your
dragon budget
for the event just so i'm sort of trying
to
get the nuts and bolts but
warren ran on how much gold do you think
everyone will eat per person all of it
okay great
warren had run on austerity so the other
guys in his party are like dude you
can't [ __ ] do this this is crazy so
warren finally goes okay no inaugural
they just do it at the white house with
a small reception sure well just a
couple friends and a dragon something
tiny yeah yeah
nothing crazy uh and then harding puts
friends in his cabinet and ned was made
i wanna let us out of here you son of a
[ __ ] you stay in there i'm the
president i've nailed it shut and you're
not coming out of there until you agree
i'm the best one in the friend group
so ned was made special agent of the
justice department he got a code book an
id badge an id card a badge instead he
was gonna plan a party and instead he's
like you know no party do you just want
to be the head of waterfield
can i be a fancy cop yes
i have no experience that's what we love
about i'm rich that's right you're gonna
understand what it's like to need to i'm
gonna shoot this guy oh well great don't
get jesus christ i'm a cop i can do that
all right let's not just shoot everyone
like i shot him
i shot a boy
i'm a cop
bang oh
someday you'll fit right in but he
prosecutes me i'm really loving that he
deputized the lizard people though
that's working out gangbusters
uh so ned is still a party boy obviously
sure it was rumored he drugged a post
reporter and took him on an ocean liner
because he wanted company on the trip
what
uh
hey
what the hell where am i what the hell's
going on we're going to morocco ned yes
what the hell are you doing here
well i wait
we're going we're on a boat yeah what
the [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is my family are
my family on the boat no no they're at
home i didn't they shouldn't be here
it's for us it's the best thing i
remember was you said you needed a
moment of my time and then we had a
drink uh-huh i put uh drugs inside the
drink and knocked you out what
why and then i had my bodyguards carry
you here and now you're on a boat i need
a friend i'm going to morocco i don't
want to do it alone
well we're going to get to know each
other i
what do you know about lizard people
this is not a good foundation to start a
friendship oh this is how most of my
friendships start
classically it's usually work friends uh
you know like gym friends and then
drugged ocean liner friends i i i
drugged him too yeah he drugged me and
brought me to the gym
yeah that's true
there's a lot of guys here from the post
hello it's us
where was the sports reporter who's
running the paper nate tried to kill us
hey we got to get you into bowling
league it's a tax write-off thing mainly
but you'll fit right in i have a bowling
alley on the boat
another gutter ball
so uh
in bars ned enjoyed knocking guys hats
off and stomping on them and then his
bodyguards would wait and how great the
[ __ ] was that and then reimburse the
hey
now you can go buy another one
this game is awesome everybody wins i'm
in charge of legal affairs
so ned and the president became drinking
buddies obviously
they uh would lead the secret service on
car chases right
they watched
shows at gatey burlesque from a
concealed box ned wants a concealed box
bro listen
put us in the coffin
ned wants peed in a fireplace at the
white house what
he owned hey this place [ __ ] sucks i
feel like the only other president of
that was trump
but he did it daily yeah yeah yeah how
long until you guys are getting the
urinal
he owned a house on eighth street that
connected to the mclean mansion next
door and he rented it to attorney
general herrity harry dougherty so it's
a party house with a regular delivery of
confiscated liquor because it's
probability oh wow right and businessmen
came to buy political favors doherty
estimated they had up to 500 visitors a
day oh my god we're gonna need help
getting this liquor off the
we can't just pour it in this into the
sewers
we need men to drink processing the
level of drinking during prohibition was
insane arguably the same amount of
drinking or maybe yeah yeah i don't
think it's because it became yeah right
i think part of me thought like maybe
some people like damn it but everybody
was just like we'll just keep drinking
we'll just keep going right
ned nicknamed this house the love nest
yeah so that means there's [ __ ] going
on
there were two poker games a week at the
white house or at one of ned's houses
florence made drinks and cooked for the
gamblers
since warren and nev ned loved golf so
much ned built a nine-hole golf course
at friendship and the sod was imported
from switzerland oh my god neither was
very good at golf so ned hired a
full-time tutor for ten thousand dollars
a year oh my god
[Music]
oh this is just too many the staff is
too much [ __ ] rich people yeah i mean
but this is on a level where i mean this
is just unreal no different than
business no no [ __ ] moon no but i
mean as far as like jet there's general
there's general being rich which is
again i mean it should be more uh
stabilize the balance but then there is
this level where it's just like you know
like you i mean i'm not saying we need
to blow people up but
it's a little out of control it's like
we need to make some a lesson or example
at some point you say this isn't okay
i'm waiting for ned to pitch that they
call themselves the regulators i'll be
ned dog you're warren g it's a thing
it's a whole club
the anti-saloon league noticed ned was a
big part of the president's life and
wrote a public warning that was
published in auto piano weekly yeah
which obviously is where you put a lot
of important stories like that
hey uh we need a political column for
the uh we're pretty booked in the
magazine this month uh article wise we
are loaded there's a lot a lot of fun
stuff going on in here what uh what
other articles you have an auto piano
weekly we have tempo oh no that's uh
trying to fix the the clicks on your
metronomes absolutely that's uh a lot of
it obviously we've got a lot of pictures
of uh pianos uh we do a whole thing on
wires yeah piano wires yeah you know
what there's piano wires and pianos yeah
no i know yeah so there's a lot of that
um we actually in this edition are
breaking down every key what we'd name
it and what its purpose is okay uh that
takes a while because i don't know do
you know how many keys are on a piano
four
four over a thousand thousand and um so
we're doing that
um then obviously we have uh mr autotune
every month we have a guy who's really
good at that and we just have him in a
suit or something it's a big picture
it's a layout
now these guys are excited to get that
uh we do a lot of stuff talk about the
pedals
pet which pedal is better you know out
of the three we take polls what's your
circulation we have well uh you know how
many are we making or how many people
are subscribing to the publication how
many people are subscribing outside of
the people who work for it yeah and
their families and their friends yeah
and the families yeah yeah there's not
anyone because this is a paper for a
family oh oh yeah this is a family paper
for pa piano people uh-huh yeah
automatic piano automatic piano people
uh which is very different than the
standard piano yeah yeah so
maybe we could do something the next
five months yeah
really tight right now it really is it's
not it's not
now this article uh called tommy go to
your room what is that that's a letter i
wrote to my son he was being a real
[ __ ] if i'm being totally honest i
found out he was putting his vegetables
out the window at dinner not eating them
yeah so this is my way of telling him
through the publication that he needs to
go upstairs and sleep it off yeah
yeah so this is piano related it seems
like a family newsletter it is a paper
for piano auto people family members
yeah
yeah are you the only auto piano people
family i'm really the only one who's
doing any of it the rest of the family
doesn't love it does anyone else in the
family read it anyone read it i know
they don't really get it they have it
they're giving it yeah they're giving it
yeah they're giving it yeah and they're
told to read it yeah yeah so it's a big
thing it's huge yeah it sounds like it's
great no it sounds really thank you
thank you anyway i need this letter
published for the president oh here we
are back to square one it's gonna be a
while
so uh
this article on autopia weekly mentioned
ned by name and said he was supposed to
have the quote most extensively stocked
seller in washington wow
so ned's not exactly subtle yeah i mean
you're yeah it's it's about his drinking
it's egregious yes right he has a pet
seal that he gives whiskey to every day
well i don't want to uh by the way
there's a lot of people who have made
the accusations that i have a pet seal
and uh you do and i do i've seen it i do
not and he certainly doesn't drink
whiskey now he's a scotch man let's dig
into what you just said
uh ned had a pet seal that he drank
whiskey with yes right okay um
now as far as laws go there are none
okay great just want to make sure no
none yeah
whiskey's just like ocean water
uh they had a small house in palm beach
and when he was there
for a seal
he gave whiskey to a trained bear and
then took it to a dance hall and tried
to get women to dance with it and they
wouldn't so he finally gave them money
so they would dance with the drunk bear
i'm sorry
um you had to be stopped earlier and you
weren't but uh
so
uh-huh
it's
really on a level that's
not okay right i mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can't get super
nice like these are all things
independently you couldn't do and this
is over the course of one night that he
got a bear drunk yeah
and when people were like holy [ __ ]
there's a bear here he's like relax i'll
pay you to dance with it
he made like a bear strip club kind of
yeah well the girls you wanted private
dance the girls no touching the bear
they didn't want to dance with it
because they were like it's a [ __ ]
drunk bear and then he's like here's a
thousand dollars okay i'll dance with
the bear don't worry it's drunk he's not
gonna make proper decisions right now
the bear's hammered he's not gonna know
what he's doing
this was reported widely like all over
the country even the piano magazines
yeah and then there's of course plenty
rumors about sex workers and ladies
coming to the love nest with the drunk
bear no the drunk bears god we're gone
i'm afraid you're gonna [ __ ] the bear do
a little more than dance
did the bear enjoy the dancing he's
wondering maybe
okay
you're asleep let's go to see the bear
let's go hey let's see this what's this
uh-huh you
me
cover your friends the bear
we go upstairs
we'll get our clothes off and
well the bear keeps his fur on he's not
gonna touch it he's just gonna watch you
on the bear to be clear yeah
nothing weird i'll go into my little box
that i go and watch movies in it's a
coffin with eye holes cut out because
you won't even
be stood up properly not in the way that
you would do it at a funeral
oh yeah christ so i get whiskey
can't we just get another couple ladies
who might sleep with this bear so bear
killed two women we're looking for
another two
so and then evelyn are fighting and over
what and the papers are writing about it
then on august 2nd 1923 the president
suddenly died of a cerebral hemorrhage
wow
did you touch the diamond
yes right the maclaine's put it on the
back of my neck for a minute
the kinds of very upset they leave dc
they tell florence to stay in the
friendship house you stay at friendship
well she does but she's trying to save
her husband's reputation and she's
burning hundreds of documents in the
fireplace
the seals handing them to her
thank you more hurry we've got to get
rid of the evidence there's a bear
[Laughter]
so
it doesn't matter look the stories of
his affairs hit the press like he's just
a womanizer everyone finds out about it
the uh
now the government had set aside oil
reserves for the navy's use right and
the secretary of the interior albert
fall took a bribe and leased the lands
without bids okay
this is the teapot dome scandal okay
and fall asked ned when people start
sniffing around
to say you loaned me a hundred thousand
dollars okay so you can say that's where
the money came from to cover the bribe
right sure take it and ned's like yeah
i'll do that that's a good idea yeah it
sounds awesome have you met my bear the
seal
and i have a steel and the bear
i think those lizard guys are real but
crazy [ __ ] happened last night [ __ ]
bear killed the seal man nobody could
see it coming
[Laughter]
they're supposed to be best friends
because of their relationships with
beach balls
tell me to give them one bottle of
whiskey then they follow i'll tell you i
didn't believe in the hope time of until
a bear killed my sail
what are the odds
so uh
so anyway he says he'll cover and say he
gave the guy a hundred thousand dollars
would take that deal i know but they're
all friends and anyway the senate
investigates i'm good a ton of wires
they find out are be sent back and forth
between the washington post ned's office
his assistant and ned in palm beach and
they're all coated
uh
the messages were from i also like milky
cereal
maybe we make sure it's extra milky and
there's not a lot of cereal in the bowl
i mean they just jumble words the air
bay octfey another way ostitude prey
and say
or may these are bad
this is not a good code
the messages are all about the illegal
deals evelyn told tells ned don't go to
the senate don't i'll go to the senate
don't go don't go to the city i'll take
the bear and we'll go i'll take the bear
we'll wear the diamond the bear is gonna
drive in the diamond car
yeah how sober are you you could try
first that's better than i have yet
one senator makes a seal noise now fyi
now one senator thinks ned is lying
about the loan because
he heard ned is broke
okay
and first ned ducks the
i mean he's broke yeah
this is brewster's millions it really is
so ned ned ducks the uh
you know the the
what do you call it a subpoena subpoena
uh he says he has a sinus infection
i can't do a subpoena my nose hurts
so you know how it goes
good to see you uh
he has his lawyers and his connections
indeed your honor my client has a stuffy
nose
the hell's he gonna do what are you
barbaric you want the man to come here
he's not an animal the man next to him
is that's his bear that's a bear
he's doing the seal thing lately because
he ate
you're on her
can we stop typing for a minute darling
uh you're on her a um
the bear aid is sealed
off the record off the record and that's
why his nose hurts
there he is so
okay
there it is is he hiccuping he is
hiccuping yeah he saw my dad do it my
dad died from hiccuping
anyway
yeah
oh boy i'm gonna have to take a look at
his will i know that that's an inside
joke am i the lawyer now
um
so
he has his lawyers and connections in dc
try to cover things up but the activity
just makes the senators more suspicious
they really where they weren't buying
the stuff he knows stuff yes but that
the investigation is going absolutely
nowhere okay and one senator gets really
focused on dead on net okay and
ned can't handle this he can't handle
the stress he puts on weight his face
looks haunted he's morose he's withdrawn
okay
and then ned goes to fall and he said
i've done as much as i can but i'm going
to tell the truth now oh god
bad time and there's a senator coming
down to interview ned because he won't
go to washington
so
ned tells him the truth and the center
is just totally shocked like it's the
teapot dome scandal he just drops it you
didn't know about that
not like you knew they had absolutely
nothing and we're about to end the
hearings oh my god [ __ ] squeal
he just squealed you got to be a good
man
dumps the whole thing in their laps
he confessed he hadn't lent for all the
money it breaks open the whole scandal
and it's the biggest scandal in american
history and up until like watergate
right
so ned's ned then goes to testify in
front of the senate and he just looks
[ __ ] dumb hi
he said things like quote i've read so
many of these telegrams my head is dizzy
senator i'm trying to figure them out
like they're just
oh god yeah he just looks like a [ __ ]
idiot right in the telegrams ned was
called
t-k-v-o-u-e-p or the chieftain or the
big bear
wow
or seal owner
yeah
so ned becomes a laughing stop stock in
the country as his messages are
published in newspapers right so
everything's out there everyone just
thinks he's yeah his texts text's right
there when you think he's a [ __ ]
idiot right both evelyn and ned are now
heavily drinking and they've got serious
money problems
so when ned needs money he would just go
to the washington post and take it cash
that's how it works in one year he took
ninety thousand dollars that's how it
works though
i just catch it i just cashed the paper
boys on their way back in from outside
give me those
he's got the beard what do you got timmy
what are you got the 50 dollars give it
to me give me a [ __ ] that's all i
have
i'm back baby
my wife i will be able to wait till she
sees us 9 000
whoo we're back
who watched about the hope diamond
i mean in today's money that's about
three million dollars that he's just
taking in cash
he's also blatantly having an affair
great so they sue each other [ __ ] the
bear
so they sue each other divorced in 1925
ned chicken like crazy he goes to mexico
and sends her divorce papers then
he sends more from latvia inside a
christmas package decorated with
reindeer and holly i want to send her
divorce papers for christmas too
it's gotta be nice
can you put some holly on there also
these are divorce papers yeah and then
oh it was a little reindeer i ho ho hope
you're right in hell
[Laughter]
so now dasher and dancer and my attorney
leonard feinstein hello i don't know why
he set it up like that but we are here
to serve you
so evelyn uses her lawyers to block it
they somehow remain married okay
i don't this part i don't understand
like i kept reading this over again and
i'm like what in the [ __ ] is happening
okay
in 1929 evelyn takes the kids and leaves
moving into little house on eighth
street
a close friend of ned says he's just
totally upset
said he was quote like a ship without a
rudder he didn't give a damn where he
went or what he did sure but they're
still married they're officially still
married and they have other kids than
vincent that's just remorse oh okay just
know they're like those are not where
the goddamn thing yeah yeah
um
terrible rumors are circulating about
ned now because he's the last terrible
rumors is the house he's staying in
right yes
the peeing in the white house fireplace
is one of the members two times wow
she's gonna put it out
i thought the fire was spreading you're
welcome i saved the white house i mean
imagine pissing in a white house i was
scared the fires kicked my bear
[Laughter]
people said he had quote urination
syndrome and had also peed on the leg of
the belgian
is how we ambassador hi here i think i
like it hello there's uh
he went to la for a few months where he
had an affair that's on the hollywood
landscape
he had an affair with rose doras she was
the sister of a famous actress who was
the mistress of ned's friend william
randolph hearst ah that's cute
ned brought rose to dc and introduce her
to staffers at the post in what was an
incredibly awkward meeting that is a
bold move yeah yeah also we need 90
grand hello
how's everyone's article
now needy money tries to sell the post
but evelyn blocks it because she wants
her boys to inherit it okay she also
tried to get ned removed as co-trustee
of his father's estate she said he was
broke and he had borrowed a hundred
hundred thousand dollars against a
property to go on a trip to rose with
rose to europe where he then ran out of
money in paris and borrowed more money
from the hotel i like to buy another
cursed diamond
always running out of money in france
yes it always seems here i don't know
how i know how this works don't worry
i've been here before it's better now
why did i buy a third bear
that has so many bears now
oh my god i bought a fifth [ __ ]
he keeps waking up
i got so drunk i bought another bear
last night sir you said to get the
bearing yes no i said we're going to
paris
jesus honey why are there six bears in
the other hotel room well it'd be fair i
only bought four of them and then
apparently late last night i ordered two
more my eyes were bigger than my tummy
so um he ends up being hospitalized in
paris for alcoholic serum
this room's only for bears this is a
bear room
uh evelyn finally sues ned for divorce
claiming desertion and non-support which
was granted in 1932.
okay
now same year in 1932 rose really caught
him at his apex didn't she really
knows when to land it uh on march 1 1932
the lindbergh baby was kidnapped and
because of the threats made to kidnap
vincent evelyn is like emotionally
attached to it very upset
so she reached out reaches out to conman
and ex-fbi agent gaston means from
episode 293
and he said he could find out where the
baby was but he needed a hundred
thousand dollars for ransom and four
thousand for personal expenses oh this
guy so she hawks the
diamond to pay for him okay
means uh means strings are along for six
weeks he said he was negotiating with
the kidnapper who he said was named the
fox i got him he's the [ __ ] and i'm
talking him right now you didn't even
send in the bear not now ned not now
buddy
then means ask for another 35 000 and
evelyn realizes she's being con and she
calls out to she reaches out to j edgar
hoover who then
means goes down okay the linsberg baby's
already dead right so means is convicted
of fraud as far as hawking the diamond
she
like the story said she did it many
times and then would get it back so
she's always hocking the diamond and
getting it back at this point when she's
broke
so ned has to give up control of the
post because he was borrowing so much
money they're finally like okay dude
you're killing the [ __ ] i mean the
paper's almost gone it's [ __ ] at this
point we can't afford ink
um
four days after he has to give up
control the
papers auctioned off wow because that's
how much money he sucked out of it wow
on june 1st 1933
evelyn bid for it
but
up until 625 000 and then she couldn't
bid anymore
the new owner
who bought uh he called it he called the
paper quote mentally morally physically
and in every other way bankrupt
ned was just wobbling that
and i said this a lot was we needed a
section about bears it's just bad news
what's going on
this guy thinks he knows how to run a
dancing with paperweight
in florida we're not covering who knows
this man
i have five bears
and they're very interesting and they
should have a paper someone shoot this
man bear wiggly
tired
you're tired
i'm asleep what now here on your feet
this man's asleep on my feet i've been
eight hundred thousand
my god he's pissing
oh god oh [ __ ] i'm wet like a seal
where's my seal you wouldn't know him oh
god
christ
that's what he sounded like okay i miss
everybody all right there's gonna be the
lip back baby oh my god this breath is
unreal so
just to this guy who bought it for 800
000 just two years earlier had offered
ned 5 million oh my god that's what
evelyn blocked oh my god this guy was
like boy you're drinking really help me
out
a couple days after the auction a
reporter tracked down ned he was now in
a hospital in montreal that treated
alcoholics quote undergoing treatment
okay
evelyn had ned declared insane and
committed
him to a sanitarium in the attic in the
act he loves addicts
turn around
the last eight years of his life were
spent in an insane asylum where he
denied he was ned mclean that's not who
i am i'm batman you idiot
anybody who
said he was ned he got violent with him
wow i'm not [ __ ] dead did he have a
name then he came up
no
no no that'd be great he died of a heart
attack in 1941 at 55 years old god he
lived hard
and uh he cut evelyn out of his will
he left who's will he didn't have a will
he wasn't right
he uh left three hundred thousand
dollars to a mistress evelyn would write
not i don't know if it was revenue i
just had a mistress um i doubt it okay
evelyn wrote a book and called ned quote
a queer queer fellow was this ned mclean
that i had married she described him as
unearned wealth in undisciplined hands
she remained for the rest of her life
funeral there's like eight bears in the
background
the bears have really taken his heart
and now an interpretive dance to see ned
off
i finally understand what he saw in this
the priest has been eaten by one of the
cubs
that's fine
reporters cub reporters are there yes
that's right
um
she remained she was still the matrix of
washington society for her whole life
okay she would wear the hope diamond all
the time wow this person
um
their daughter name one bad thing it did
thank you
their daughter wore the hope diamond at
her wedding to senator robert reynolds
wow
it was his fifth marriage he was 57 she
was 19. great that sounds like the
diamond's already working it's magic he
was a nazi apologist
co-owner of a fascist anti-semitic paper
great great six years later
uh evelyn's daughter committed suicide
by [ __ ] lot by what laudanum
ah
evelyn never got over it
her money issues took a toll she died a
few months later on april 26 1947 of
pneumonia i don't believe in the curse
she was said to be wearing the hope
diamond at the time oh my god it was
sold to jeweler harry winston to pay
evelyn's estate taxes
he donated the gem to the smithsonian
institute
some say the tragedy in her life was due
to the hope diamond others say no it's
alcoholism and being rich and everything
else well it's clearly the diamond the
hope diamond is now valued at 200
million dollars don't touch it
is that it's still going to be
sony smith yeah
well that winston guy owns it but he
it's in the smithsonian it's safely
residing in the nation's capital where
nothing is being cursed
man if we realized the key to solving
all this is just getting the hope
diamond into the ocean can we just move
it
um wow
sources uh
dan and leslie landrigan uh
bar harbor babylon
bill hogan the article losing it
uh pbs.org and the washington post
oh wow good lord i mean this thing i get
it yeah
it's i pictured it bigger
yeah i mean that's pretty big for a
diamond though you know yeah i think
it's the i think i have bigger i think i
think it's the color that everyone loves
i have bigger and more colorful
on me
in the car i literally have a bigger
better boulder diamond
the car would just hit the child of a
wealthy couple yeah that car that i hit
a bus with and then just took off
um
what do you believe dave
curse or alcoholism that's a new game
show
i think that bad things happen to rich
people
yeah well i mean generally you know just
careless
the level of carelessness well yeah
there's a you know these people
destroyed their own life the drinking
and everything else and yeah once you
bring bears into the house it's kind of
like
but look i mean you know a kid running
out in the street how much was that kid
we know how they raised you know they
were raised and stuff how much how many
boundaries did that kid have in the
first place like you know what i mean
like it's all sort of relative well you
outsourced your love
yes you're like protect him
yeah please we don't want to touch him
it's worth mentioning that was the only
child hit by a car in the 1800s right
yeah i mean kids are [ __ ] constantly
like i mean honestly yeah
um
that is crazy yeah i mean
i i think in many ways like it
like it's amazing how rich some people
are right now
but same level
what's that same level yeah yeah and and
how comfortable we are with it and how
like
there's so much
i i people still there are a lot of
people who still are like
it's just awesome that they make that
much money you know and it's just like
we have a we have um decided that people
have their favorite billionaires right
they're like bill gates they like
but to get to be a billionaire you have
to uh brutalize human beings yeah you
shouldn't if you have the impulse to
have that much money it's a red flag
like they're in in the new bill
supposedly there's an there's a credit
for uh ev buying like eight thousand
dollars
but it's twelve thousand five hundred if
you buy it from a union company and elon
musk is flipping out right right so yeah
right well [ __ ] off yeah like
you know you don't you're the richest
man in the world you can you can [ __ ]
unionize your [ __ ] workers [ __ ] you
go [ __ ] yourself your little baby like
it's and he's also he's just a
government sponge like he's made all of
his money off of government technology
and everything else but also it's like
he wanting to be that is a is a
psychological disorder well i think he's
just trying to make up for the fact that
he doesn't have enough money to buy the
hope diamond off the smithsonian
and i think people should get in his ear
about that and taunt him i want him
interested in purchasing the whole
diamond oh yeah i mean sure your dad
owned that emerald mine but did you ever
own the hope diamond and the answer is
not yet and let's get it in his hands
well and it's also it's nice to look
back and be like man it's nice that we
don't have a [ __ ] psychotic rich
person running the washington post
anymore
[Laughter]
and look people don't remember but bill
gates was in the 90s a terrible
[ __ ] human being he was our villain
he was one of the main villains and now
he's gone i mean he's like donating
money to msnbc and johnny and the
guardians and i don't even hang out with
jeffrey anymore
allegedly i mean he went he went to an
island with jeffrey and then his wife
stopped [ __ ] talking to him and
eventually divorced him because then
when he got interviewed about it yeah
it's amazing and she's like is there a
lesson we learned he was like well he's
dead
yeah and there's a long pause while judy
woodruff's like
sip of water while i process what you
just said yeah i mean we'll do a bill
gates episode at some point but he's
he's an awful awful human yeah the love
that we have for billionaires again i
think yeah no so everyone's got a
favorite billionaire so then they don't
want to harm billionaires well they they
i think again i mean it's like you know
i mean in a lot of ways the american
dream is predicated on the fact that you
do it on the backs of others
and so if the idea is that in this
country anyone can achieve any level of
success i understand why people are
attracted to that when you see it
actually put
into
and when people are actually doing it
it's disgusting i mean it's crazy the i
mean when you look at over the pandemic
year how rich these people got and i
mean
they should they're very illusion at the
very least they should lose every dollar
they made during the pandemic yeah one
out of five families lost their entire
people i think also see when people like
bill gates has done you know some
philanthropic work i mean as as most
billionaires do but you need to
look at how i mean it is we are talking
about like they are just tipping well i
mean it they have so much [ __ ] money
he always says i'm giving away my money
but every year he has more money yes and
also the [ __ ] with the vaccine when he
when it was he he got them to stop uh
you know we're gonna like yeah they're
gonna give away give away the recipe to
make these he killed he killed tom so
now in africa you know what they're
doing they're like backwards like trying
to figure out how to [ __ ] make this
[ __ ] of course just like what
i mean
what is enough
the only thing that gets me out of bed
every morning is the motivation that one
day it might be my boot on the necks of
my friends and family
and that's what keeps me going
one day baby
uh thank you for joining us luke thank
you for having me thank you thank you
aaron
thanks your dog thank you dave yeah good
uh good timing with the dog and thank
you the lord above you're a man you have
a beard you are mandels you're in the
clouds you've decided all of it we are
all part of your plan and it's going
really really well we're excited to see
it through and we're all going to be
seeing you real real soon champ thanks
everybody
go to
dollarpockets.com tickets
you